[Music]
what's up everybody michael here today
we're serving up a fresh grill take on
the hungriest and one of the horniest
sitcom families in adult animation the
belchers from bob's burgers with 12
seasons and a new feature film to their
name they've cooked up plenty for us to
talk about all that matters is you're a
man now in love with the mannequin who
i'm holding by the arm but should be in
yours but today we want to focus on how
the belchers function as a family unit
bob and his wife linda are busy running
a burger joint and as such they don't
have a ton of time for their kids at
least by the standards of today's
helicopter parents as a result the
children tina jean and louise get to
wander off on their own adventures while
their parents work to keep the lights on
this makes for a well-structured episode
of television but it also begs the
question are bob and linda bad parents
we don't know all the crazy crap our
kids are doing we don't want to know to
answer that we have to look at how
society defines good and bad parenting
in the first place and we'll also have
to ask are nuclear families even the
best way to raise a kid let's get into
the meat of it and chomp down on this
wisecrag edition on bob's burgers do you
even need your parents and of course
spoilers ahead for the tv show though
eccentric the belters are a fair
representation of the contemporary
american family where the soul male
breadwinner and female homemaker have
been replaced by two parents working
full-time jobs thanks to evolving gender
roles and changing economic realities
fifty dollars for that fifty dollars is
a little gear a horse and a zimbaby this
leaves parents with collectively less
time and energy for their tots for their
part both belchers struggle to find a
healthy work-life balance and without
hovering parentals to interfere the kids
are free to frolic about town without
appointed adult supervision i don't get
it whether they're exploring an
abandoned taffy factory or taking a
ferry to go trick-or-treating at rich
people's houses the belcher kids are
frequently left to fend for themselves
for folks who favor a more involved mode
of child rearing this might set off
alarm bells surely a lack of parental
supervision would leave the belcher kids
with irreparable feelings of neglect
right well not really in fact these kids
are pretty well adjusted sure louise
finds herself in trouble here and there
what are kids doing what knife and yeah
tina could probably use some more help
navigating puberty my crotch is itchy
okay
are you telling me as my daughter or as
my grill cook still their issues rarely
cause anything but trivial problems
critically though this is largely
because of the many neighbors who pick
up the slack when bob and linda aren't
around these adults seemingly share the
communal goal of ensuring that the
belcher kids turn out all right they all
step in at various points to look after
the kids and teach them lessons that
their parents don't gene tina what are
you two doing here learning to paint
we're honing our craft wait i thought
you hated my kids my art workshop is
open to all who respect art because of
their constant interactions with their
adult neighbors the belcher kids are
exposed to a multitude of different
lifestyles and perspectives take teddy
the restaurant's most loyal patron while
he's a passive lonely dude who's easy
for the kids to target with pranks he's
also the first person they call when
they're in trouble maybe they need to
hack into the school's electrical
circuit for stage magic reasons maybe
they need someone to negotiate with the
cops to keep tina out of jail a mission
that helps to earn him the fleeting
moniker of uncle teddy while the kids
might just be looking out for their own
self-interest teddy clearly has traits
that they feel their parents lack or
take mr frond yes watching over the
belcher kids is technically part of his
job at wagstaff elementary but as the
world's most intense guidance counselor
he takes a student's emotional welfare
extremely seriously from him the kids
learn lessons like perfectionism has its
limits nobody wants a relatable guidance
counselor kids think i'm perfect that's
why they listen to me and don't frame
your students for a crime to cover up
how you've mishandled school funds no
matter how delicious your new coffee
pods are attention there has been a
grisly crime committed in my office my
therapy dolls have been mutilated and
because he's so fixated on whether or
not these kids are breaking school rules
the young belchers are frequently
challenged to point out the nuances and
gray areas of complicated situations
even if piping up lands them in
detention or music videos let's swap
eyes so we can
and don't forget the extended belcher
family like linda's sister gayle even
though her pensions for crying painting
animal buttholes and sneaking bites of
cat food you gotta warm it up and put it
on your oatmeal make the kids a little
wary of her they know she's ultimately a
safe person to run to when there's
trouble like when louise runs away to
stay with aunt gayle to avoid seeing the
dentist even if she's in for an intense
experience time to get some shut-eyes
why must the world end right when i'm
getting sleepy
importantly aunt gayle eventually
teaches louise to be brave and face her
fears or risk growing up to be like her
you've seen my life yeah it's bad but
despite all of her eccentricities the
kids understand that time spent with
aunt gayle is a crash course in radical
empathy and the power of white lies to
keep the peace i did it i did it i fixed
all the paintings i added pants and huge
pendulous breasts what do you think
gail it's beautiful they're great
another adult friend in their community
is marshmallow the transex worker whose
identity is fully respected marshmallow
acts as a role model for
self-determination independence and
creative expression
tall dark and handsome that settles it
mom's psychic no she isn't marshmallow
isn't handsome she's beautiful blush
even characters who are supposed to be
villains like mr fischoeder the landlord
actually accidentally add value to the
kids lives beyond proving that you can
wear white after labor day mr fischoeder
helps the kids improve their bargaining
skills i take ious at other points his
own deeply rotten ethical code actually
serves as a helpful contrast to their
own developing moral compasses you know
the basics like it's bad to threaten to
evict your tenants unless they pose as
your family at thanksgiving just so you
can trick a date into having sex with
you give me those lips no lips
[Music]
or that you shouldn't teach children how
to cheat at games so you can keep your
arcade's profits high it's a good thing
i was expecting this and was able to
catch them but you taught us to see yeah
you did are you dirty dogging us i've
never seen you before in my long and
prosperous life although to be fair the
kids learned some pretty sweet heist
skills from this debacle and just like
in real life the kids regularly
encounter people whose sense of morality
or even reality is a little tenuous what
are those pretty buttons oh these
patches well we got this one for tickle
and a cop oh what's that one for for not
being associated with the white power
movement you think you're a mannequin oh
no it's okay you don't need to be scared
of me i'm not one of those murder
mannequins or satanic mannequins
cumulatively these interactions with
most of the townsfolk make the belcher
kids better people you're all willing to
give up your christmas presents for chet
they're exposed to more perspectives
outside of their parents world views and
they're emboldened and trusted by their
parents to make their own decisions well
for the most part found a perfectly good
mirror to smash on the way home and
everybody made me feel weird about it oh
i love smashing a good mirror lin right
playing with glass isn't a good idea all
three of the belcher babies seem to
exude an emotional maturity far
exceeding that of their peers and you
could argue that it may come directly
from this mode of child rearing and bob
and linda's parenting style can actually
teach us how to view family in a
radically different way how thoughtful
of you all but i don't need a hat to
complete me i'm all i need just me for a
long time it was assumed that humans
evolved so successfully in part due to a
family dynamic wherein males would hunt
for food and portion that food for their
mates and offspring and the families
that did this the best survived to
produce more offspring but moderate
anthropologists have started to cast
doubt on this hypothesis suggesting
instead that communal parenting played a
much bigger role in our evolution this
method of shared parenting is called
aloe parenting as anthropologist david
lancy explains all of parenting is based
on the notion that all sorts of folks
can step up and play what we think of as
the normal parenting role all the
various parenting roles can be
distributed and collectively those folks
are called allo parents this has
significant benefits for prehistoric
human tribes if a male was bad at
hunting or if a female had lactation
issues it didn't necessarily mean that
their offspring would have less of a
chance of survival this sharing of
resources and responsibility led to more
offspring surviving overall lancy
explained the payoff of allo parenting
is that our species grew very rapidly
over time compared to say our nearest
relatives the chimpanzees although
parenting is obviously no longer
dominant in industrialized nations but
we still implement elements of this
parenting method today to an extent we
send our kids to schools or houses of
worship to learn from experts and
parents often share child care
responsibilities with their own parents
or siblings those with the resources
also might yield some of their parenting
duties to day cares babysitters nannies
au pairs you get the idea as the saying
goes it takes a village to raise a child
bob and linda seem to instinctively know
this and they generally trust their own
village to raise their children in an
organic and communal way without the
commercial exchange that comes with
babysitting or daycare they don't try to
shield their kids from pretty much
anyone they have no problem with their
kids hanging out with nudists or sex
workers or even bank robbers bob and
linda don't have to teach their kids
acceptance it just becomes their default
response to the different lifestyles
they encounter so what happened alo
parenting obviously a lot of social and
cultural changes brought us from the
earliest hunter-gatherer tribes to
modern american life but even as late as
1900 it was still common to live in
large households with big extended
families this meant more people to offer
childcare worldly advice shoulders to
cry on etc etc extended families didn't
vanish but rampant industrial migration
into big cities bred smaller familial
units and this shift was intensely
amplified by post-world war ii cultural
ideals of you guessed it the nuclear
family kids were increasingly siloed off
into units of two parents one
breadwinner one caretaker supporting
them without substantial outside
involvement and this was long hailed in
popular culture as a paragon of healthy
child development interestingly enough
bob's burgers couples its celebration of
a sort of ollo parenting by frequently
critiquing your typical nuclear family
relationships for example tina's
recurring love interest jimmy jr has a
far more dysfunctional relationship with
his father than tina he resents his
father jimmy pesto who disapproves of
his son's passion for dance don't tell
me not to dance dad it seems that jimmy
feels determined to pass down his own
conception of masculinity onto jimmy jr
which doesn't include dancing you see
bob i'm a collector of rare and exotic
trophies and jimmy jr unfortunately
doesn't have another surrogate father
figure to offer support meanwhile jean's
occasional love interest courtney has
her life micromanaged by her own father
who attempts to live vicariously through
her to achieve what he never could like
when he writes a working girl musical
for the kids at school to perform and
tries to make courtney pass it off as
her own work i wrote a play we're doing
it tomorrow see you there or like when
he gets a little too emotionally
invested in being courtney's temporary
roller dancing coach you are ruining our
dreams i don't even like doing this this
is your thing while bob and linda are
there to offer a guiding hand when
needed they rarely take a disciplinary
approach and they don't really do much
to steer their children's interest or
behavior this allows the kids to fully
explore their identities while figuring
out important life lessons for
themselves they don't try to suppress
tina's sometimes robust sexual urges she
knew what she had to do she grabbed
jimmy junior's butt and change the world
instead they allow her to learn and
develop healthy boundaries from those
around her sometimes by trial and error
what's tina doing out there becoming a
woman oh i can't tell where your back
ends and your butt begins the belters
also encouraged jean's passion for music
and theater stop that singing right now
nobody tells my son to stop singing and
while they do their best to channel
louise's anarchistic urges productively
they don't use a heavy hand preferring
to talk to her like a peer like after
she lands an in-school suspension for
panting a bully in the cafeteria and
linda bails her out what you did was
wrong yeah everybody made that pretty
clear but i don't want you getting the
idea that helping people isn't worth it
louise because it is when we consider
that so many other adults have
significant influence over the belcher
kids lives we have to ask are parents
all that important when it comes to
raising kids our collective social
fixation on the sacred nuclear family
continues today even as our definitions
of marriage and families evolve there's
a continued emphasis on the importance
of children being raised by two adults
in a romantic relationship and while
there is certainly data that suggests
that divorce or absent parents can have
negative impacts on children there's
also plenty of evidence to suggest that
marriage might not be so great for
raising kids either philosopher and
children's rights advocate samantha
brennan contends that shifting away from
our cultural hyper focus on marriage can
mitigate some of the worst dangers
resulting from the close link between
marriage and parenthood which largely
result from the instability tension and
even violence that too often form a
central part of romantic conflict which
makes sense witnessing domestic
arguments or at worst violence can have
devastating effects on children they can
pass that trauma onto their own kids we
see bob confront this kind of
generational trauma when he realizes
that in making his kids stay inside and
work on a fun summer day he's being just
like his dad lin i just realized
something i had a bad childhood yeah i
know crucially he decides then and there
to break that vicious cycle at least for
the day i want you to go out and have
the summer and the childhood that i
never had of course this results in the
kids unwittingly working for drug
dealers but at least they learned some
valuable lessons from that experience if
the po-po rolls up the first calls to
your lawyer not your mom it seems that
every generation of parents faces a new
moral panic about what their children
are being exposed to whether it's rock
and roll video games or dungeons and
dragons there's no shortage of external
forces to blame for corrupting the youth
it's natural for parents to want to
shield their children from harm but
sometimes that sheltering can be harmful
in and of itself one american
psychological association study found
that children with helicopter parents
may be less able to deal with the
challenging demands of growing up
especially with navigating the complex
school environment and had more trouble
regulating their own emotions and making
friends giving kids autonomy then is
important what's more by giving their
children free reign the belchers
effectively outsource some of their
parental duties to their family friends
and neighbors lessening their own strain
in the process nowadays despite its
continued veneration the reality is that
many families no longer look nuclear
often being composed of single or
divorced parents in this landscape
extended family or surrogate parent
figures become more important than ever
particularly if your family isn't loaded
while wealthy families of any formation
can afford to pay for hollow parenting
privileges like daycares or bassoon
lessons the biggest consequences of
collapsed social networks and extended
families hit those with the least
resources even conservative columnist
david brooks argues that successfully
maintaining a nuclear family today has a
lot more to do with class than anything
else writing affluent conservatives
often pat themselves on the back for
having stable nuclear families they
preach that everybody else should build
stable families too but then they ignore
one of the main reasons their own
families are stable they can afford to
purchase the support that extended
family used to provide and that the
people they preach at further down the
income scale cannot it's like a real
life version of that famous click hole
headline at the same time we're seeing
less social and financial support being
provided to families than ever with the
slash into the child tax credit sending
almost 4 million kids into poverty
seemingly overnight nuclear and
non-nuclear families alike who lack
economic resources are faced with
unreasonable burdens and expectations of
what good parenting should look like for
the working class belchers their
solution to rely on friends and family
might just be the best way to cope with
the realities that many families face
today and as we see with the belchers
this support can ultimately make the
family unit even stronger the comfort of
knowing everyone is safe and well cared
for well most of the time alleviates
stress each belcher is free to grow as a
person on their own terms in other words
the belchers prove that you don't have
to spend all your time with your nuclear
family to still love the [ __ ] out of
them kids i love you and linda i love
you too almost as much as the kids but
bobby i love you too what's more bob's
burgers shows us that a society
structured to allow children to reap the
benefits of aloe parenting rather than
making raising children exclusively the
domain of the nuclear family is one that
fosters the development of smart savvy
and yes occasionally devious tots but
what do you guys think are the belchers
a model for a more adaptive family unit
do nuclear families ruin us let us know
in the comments thanks to our patrons
for all your support and don't forget to
check out our new perks on patreon and
check out our new stream wisecrack live
thursdays at 11am pacific time hit that
subscribe button like your thomas edison
electrocuting topsy and don't forget to
ring that bell as always thanks for
watching and remember i love you but
you're all terrible
[Music]
you
[Music]